temps monsieur paul salen oui merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre je
voudrais associer cette question mon
collègue dino cinieri monsieur le
premier ministre
suite à l'adoption de non loin d'autres
dans chaque département les commissions
départementales de coopération
intercommunale se sont réunis à de
nombreuses reprises afin de procéder au
niveau découpage des communautés de
communes dans les départements et ceci
en concertation avec l'ensemble des élus
locaux
cependant dans certains départements il
semblerait que les préfets ont reçu des
consignes afin que le permettent d
arrondissement se rapproche de plus
possible de celui des communautés de
communes ou des communautés
d'agglomération
c'était à de faire entraîner le
transfert de communes d'un
arrondissement à l'autre sans qu'aucune
concertation ne soient menées ni avec
les élus de cet arrondissement
ni même au sein de la commission
départementale de coopération
intercommunale
désormais le jus du gouvernement
apparaît clairement supprimer des
arrondissements préfectoraux sans
concertation et en casalta logique
territoriale d'inventer platement
certaines communes de l'arrondissement
de montbrison pourrait être ainsi
transférés dans l'arrondissement de
saint-etienne vie dans l'arrondissement
de montbrison d'un grand nombre de ses
communes sans que les élus locaux n'ont
été prévenus cet arrondissement se
retrouva donc coincé entre deux grosses
agglomérations celle de saint-etienne et
celle de juan et sa diviserait le ferait
entre ces deux agglomérations
nulle part dans la loi notre il n'est
précisé que ce découpage doha les
périmètres des arrondissements et des
communautés de communes ou
d'agglomération devenir identique
aussi monsieur le premier league je
souhaiterais vous poser trois questions
est il vrai qu'une consigne était donnée
aux préfets et visant à faire coïncider
le père immédiat des arrondissements
avec le périmètre des communautés de
communes ou d'agglomération
et si cette consigne donnée en catimini
au préfet ne serait-elle pas l'abus du
souhait de voir disparaître de nombreux
arrondissements en l'occurrence celui de
montbrison dans mon département sans
l'assumer pleinement devant les élus
locaux et les habitants de ces communes
enfin dit nous réellement quel est le
nom de sous préfecture que vous pensez
supprimés merci la parole et à monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur je député je commence par
votre dernière question combien de sous
préfecture souhaitons nous
supprimer aucune je vous signale
d'ailleurs que ceux qui ont supprimé le
plus emplois dans les préfectures et les
sous préfectures c'est vous puisque en
l'espace de cinq ans vous aurez
supprimer exactement 2725 emplois dans
les préfectures et les sous-préfectures
et croyez moi les personnels des
préfectures et sous-préfectures s'en
souviennent quand on sait qu'il ya à peu
près 220 employés dans les préfectures
en france ce que vous avez supprimé
comme l'emploi est à peu près
l'équivalent d'une douzaine de
préfecture donc ne vous inquiétez pas du
tout les préfectures et sous préfectures
qui ont été supprimés ils ont été
supprimés propos ici la raison pour
laquelle nous n'avons pas l'intention du
tout de poursuivre cette action funès
première question deuxième question vous
m'interrogez sur le fait de savoir s'il
est vrai que nous allons travailler sur
les arrondissements oui c'est vrai
est-ce que ça va aboutir à la
suppression d'arrondissement absolument
pas vous savez qu'il ya en france depuis
poincaré 1926 60,35 arrondissement que
sur ces 335 arrondissement nous allons
procéder à la fusion de deux d'entre eux
et au jumelage de six d'entre eux donc
je ne sais pas où vous voyez des
arrondissements disparaître en tous les
cas ce qui fusionneront représente deux
arrondissements sur 335 c'est une donc
une deuxième erreur
la troisième question que vous me posez
c'est de savoir s'il ya une instruction
qui a été donnée au préfet de modifier
les frontières des arrondissements bah
oui à une instruction qui était donnée
au préfet le modifier les frontières des
arrondissements en très étroite
concertation avec les élus qui pour la
plupart d'entre eux ont été consultés et
qui pour beaucoup d'entre eux d'ailleurs
s'en félicite pourquoi parce que les
arrondissements ce n'est pas une
création ex nihilo qui ne correspond à
rien les arrondissements ça correspond
aux tissus intercommunale et à partir du
moment où diminue par deux le nombre
d'intercommunalités dans un certain
nombre de territoires sauf à être
complètement archaïque et refusé toute
modernisation du pays
il est tout à fait logique que nous
procédions à la modernisation des
arrondissements donc oui nous le faisons
parce que nous sommes modernisateur et
nous faisons dans le cadre d'un
comportement de l'administration
préfectorale partout dans la république
merci la séance des questions au
gouvernement et terminer la séance